okay so the Indiana Jones 5 trailer has
just dropped online and throughout this
video we're going to be bringing you a
big breakdown to discuss all the plot
details Easter eggs and our thoughts on
how the movie looks this is Indy's last
Last Crusade and it's apparently gonna
be the final swan song for the character
which I've heard that before now in this
video we'll be going over some of the
plot details discussed in the recent
Empire article and because of this there
may be some spoilers I haven't read any
of the leaks as a wanna go in as fresh
out as you guys but that's just
something to bear in mind when you're
watching this video if you're still here
thank you for clicking this I'm your
host Paul aka the guy whose careers in
Ruins like an archaeological dig now
let's get into the video now elements of
this trailer leaked a couple of months
back after d23 Anna contained most of
the stuff that we see here we know from
the Empire article that the movie will
be taking place in 1969
and it'll have Indie going toe-toe once
more with the Nazis so it must be fine
NASA hey having that oh [ __ ] he actually
is so in case you don't know Operation
Paperclip was started in 1945 and it
involved the US recruiting more than
1600 scientists to help assist in the
space race this led to many of them
going to NASA and in the Empire article
it was revealed by Jazz Butterworth that
Indy will discover this fact he'd be a
bit annoyed that many of the people who
are trying to beat the Russians to the
moon are actually also people that the
government were fighting less than 20
years before he'll discover that some of
the ex-nazis aren't so X and this will
be what the main plot centers around
enter mads Mickelson who will be playing
the character vola Walla is actually
going to be based on the real life
figure Werner Von Brown who was
recruited by NASA from Germany to become
an engineer during the time period Von
Brown helped to develop the V2 rocket
for the Germans and because of this he
was welcome with open arms when speaking
with Empire mad said that the villain
has discovered something that could
change the world and that he wants to
get his hands in it which will probably
be some ancient artifact that will help
him to to alter reality now because of
its closeness to real life we'll also
see a major event in history and this is
the Apollo 11 ticker type parade this
took place in New York on the 13th of
August 1969 and it was thrown us away to
celebrate the entire moon landing
Mission you see a big scene involving
this in the trailer and also bride
holbrook's character claiber described
as being well as lapdog he's gonna
chasten me through the streets of New
York in a big action scene now the 60s
brings a lot with it and we already know
that Indy's favorite band is the Rolling
Stones so he's probably gonna love it
here
now it is fictional biography Indiana
Jones was born on July 1st 1899. this
puts him at 70 years old Raz Ford is 80
in real life guys still playing younger
than his age and I know most people's
big worry about the movie is whether he
can still pull this off but the teaser
has him doing a number of things and we
already know that he's gonna be the age
at at least one point in the movie and
the film itself will be a classic trip
through several locations including a
desert city complete with a rickshaw
Chase there's a deep sea Voyage possibly
turn out the artifact caves trains
planes and Automobiles we'll also be
getting the return of John Reese Davies
whose voiceover we can hear on the
teaser it's a big return for the
franchise and generous Davies actually
turned down appearing in Crystal's skull
because he was just getting a cameo role
he said in an interview that he was just
gonna appear at the wedding and he
thought his character was worth more
than that so let's hope that he's in
this in a much bigger way now Indy of
course got married to Marion at the end
of that film and you can see in the
promotional material that he's still
wearing his wedding ring well a Karen
Allen returns or not remains to be seen
but I hope she doesn't come back she
drank more than men and they went woke
they went walk
now on a totally unrelated subject
Phoebe Waller bridge will be playing
indie's goddaughter Helena in the film
she'll be coming along for the ride with
him and will be one of the Mainstay
characters we're not sure exactly what's
going to be going on with her but I
definitely recommend that you check out
fleabag if you want to see the sort of
vibe she's probably gonna be bringing to
the film she has worked with one of
Harrison's characters before in Solo and
it's going to be nice to see them
teaming up she's a really funny actress
it looks like they're bringing her a lot
into the movie just guessing here but I
can imagine that she's following in her
Godfather's footsteps and that she's the
one who knows the plan by all the bad
guys now with her being his goddaughter
it's even possible that she's the last
kid sure he's an Egyptian character but
generous Davies is Welsh so just ignore
it don't tell anyone and no one's gonna
get offended now since 1957 India has
been stuck in the classroom collecting
books and teaching students who probably
still write stuff on their eyelids to
woo him either way to him the days of
Adventure are over but to Laura's
attempt tempting to womb back himself by
suggesting that they might not be gone
so I was very independent and it's even
possible that if we're right about him
being Helena's father that will go to
Indy so he can help rescue her either
way it doesn't seem like the good days
are over as this teaser trailer is
filled with lots of major moments and
really cool action scenes I love all
this stuff on Horseback and we know from
the d23 footage that there's gonna be a
ton of extra scenes like this that
weren't sure in the official Online
release there's gonna be big rides to
New York through the subway and through
the night along with a big motorbike
Chase Indy says that he doesn't believe
in magic but that he's seen things in
his life he can't explain and that he
believes it's not so much what you
believe but how hard you believe it I
think this is very much a way to the
audience to just believe that an 80 year
old man could do this stuff and hey I
believe mate just dust off the hat and
make a good movie and I'll be happy now
because of his age there are also
theories that the movie will culminate
with him dying I really don't know if if
Indiana Jones is the kind of character
that they kill off and I I just don't
know how they handle that if it ever
came to it I really hope that he gets
his happy ending because he is the kind
of person you do just want to see right
off into the sunset oh wait they already
did that well [ __ ] them kill him and the
teaser trailer ended with Andy using his
whip whilst getting guns drawn on him
clear reference to writers of the Lost
Ark namely the scene in which he shot
that guy and hit the like button great
little twist on that scene and the
perfect way to end the trailer now as
for my thoughts on the teaser I really
enjoyed it and I've been a big Indie fan
for as long as I can remember this guide
one of the best movie trilogies ever
made and I think everyone who's my age
crew with him in some form or another
whether it was being scared shirtless of
Temple of Doom or even the River Phoenix
opening in Last Crusade every movie had
something that's burned into my brain
now because of this love I am always
wary when I hear that they're making
another one the last one sucked balls in
my opinion at least and because of this
when I heard that this movie was
announced I was like oh [ __ ] here we go
again however after watching the trailer
I have high hopes for it I am excited to
see what happens in it Spielberg not
being at the helm is a changer but
Mangold has been behind a lot of good
films so I have faith that he can do
something good with it interestingly my
wife actually seen Harrison Ford when
she was down the keysight in Newcastle
and she said she's seen him and only
realized after it was him it was a lucky
Escape for me and if you'd seen Pete
Davidson then I'd probably be divorced
right now anyway that's the trailer and
I hope you enjoyed the breakdown there's
probably some stuff we missed in it too
so if you noticed anything then make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in competition right now giving
away three copies of House of the Dragon
season 1 on the 15th of December and all
you have to do to be when the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the trailer we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on Twitter at spoilers if you want
another trailer video then we actually
got to see the Loki season 2 on so yeah
go head over there right after this if
you if you want to know what happens in
it if you don't what the hell is wrong
with your Channel's called heavy
spoilers do one I'll see you next time
have a good week peace